parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
je t'écris ces quelques lignes pour te
dire que oui je suis prêt à faire un
petit bout de chemin avec toi ps quand
je parle de bout de chemin je veux dire
départ de chez moi arriver au boulot
puis retour mais aussi possible tous les
jours
merci à toi le covoiturage c'est
convivial économique et écologique
avec le covoiturage saint quentin en
yvelines vous propose une nouvelle façon
de vous déplacer
les inscriptions et les infos sur
www.covoiturage.fr lotir et est-ce qu y
point fr
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro d' équilibre le magazine
de l'environnement au sommaire la faute
de la science au qui marque la rencontre
contre les scientifiques et le public
nous évoquons également les problèmes de
déperdition d'énergie au sein des
habitations à travers les mesures
thermographique effectué au sein de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
mais avant sa part le science nous
sommes ici dans le centre de diffusion
artistique de poissy aux côtés de
dominique marronniers bonjour bonjour
vous êtes l'une des responsables
ile-de-france de l'association planète
sciences pourquoi nous accueillir ici
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe alors
il fallait ici dans le cadre de la fête
de la science
il s'agit de sylla me ferme étaient
comptés dans un décor de alice au pays
des merveilles pour tout ce qui est
logique il loge isme se côtoient dans un
bain de culture scientifique où se
promènent au fil du temps au fil des
mesures où l'on va aborder les
mathématiques autrement pour réconcilier
pour certains enfants
ceci avec les mathématiques avec les
sciences alors qu'elle les objectifs
quels sont les objectifs de planète
sciences
alors les objectifs de planète sciences
sont de permettre aux jeunes de
pratiquer des activités scientifiques et
techniques
alors activités au sens large puisque
initialement il ya 50 ans l'association
nationale n'est sec autour de la
thématique espaces et au fil des années
celle ci laisse largement développée en
ouvrant tous les champs possibles de la
découverte des sciences pour les pour
les plus jeunes et très vite que ce que
vous pouvez nous dire quelles sont les
thématiques et qui fascine le plus
aujourd'hui alors les thématiques qui
fascine toujours autant ce sont autour
de l'espace un bon tour de l'astronomie
tout ce qu' il ya toujours certains
connus s'il est présent
et les enfants sont toujours très
vorace pour pouvoir comprendre enfin du
moins essayer de comprendre et puis ils
émettent votre hypothèse c'est un peu le
fondement de notre association à perm
est la démarche expérimentale donc ils
émettent des hypothèses mais aussi des
représentations sur lesquels enfin à
partir desquels on part et puis on
essaye de payer pour les amener à une
compréhension de plus proche des
réalités scientifiques que on s'éloigne
un peu l'imaginaire tout en ayant
l'imaginaire comme porte d'entrée pour
accéder à des choses un peu plus
raisonnée
considérez d'accord merci beaucoup en
tout cas nous avoir reçu dans ses locaux
nous allons aussi développer la fête de
la science qui s'est déroulée dans les
locaux de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
l'occasion pour de jeunes enfants de
s'initier à tous les rouages de ce
domaine regardez ce robot est aller sur
mars
forcément ça intrigue le jeune public
venu à l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines
à l'occasion de la fête nationale de la
science la rencontre entre le rover
curiosity et les enfants est l'occasion
pour les scientifiques d'attirer de
futures adeptes à ce petit groupe on
arrive toujours à maîtriser leur faire
passer le message
le leur dire que quand qu'il fasse plus
tard dans les études
il prend toujours peut-être travailler
pour le spatial
cette journée fut l'occasion pour les
chercheurs d'expliquer aux jeunes
publics leur métier c'est leur projet
ainsi que leurs habitudes de travail au
quotidien
pourquoi quand on respire et la vapeur
d'eau qui va sortir
et comme on est dans des pierres dans
des pièces où on essaie d'abord
justement le minimum d'eau dans l'air
entre les ondes l'atmosphère et autres
capteurs les visiteurs d'un jour en ont
pris plein les yeux et les oreilles
alors bilan de la journée
qu'est ce que le rover curiosity
et un robot américain qui a été envoyée
sur mars et qui qui et qui est capable
de 2 il est capable de d'analysé des
roches dont et aussi les îles à un mini
laboratoire dans son dans son corps j'ai
aussi appris comment c'est pourquoi
météo et et pour tester les appareils
avant de les envoyer sur géant sur dans
l'espèce
bref de quoi tirer des plans sur la
comète
nous poursuivons ce numéro d' équilibre
spécial fête de la science nous sommes
désormais dans les locaux de l'inra
l'institut scientifique de recherche
agronomique à thiverval grignon
nous sommes en présence de marie-hélène
thibault chercheurs en pathologie
végétale bonjour alors pouvez vous nous
expliquer où nous nous trouvons dans
quelle pièce nous sommes alors ici nous
sommes dans un laboratoire de biologie
moléculaire dans un bâtiment dans lequel
l'ensemble des chercheurs font ce qu'on
appelle au sens large de la pathologie
végétale
donc en fait nous nous intéressons à
l'étude des maladies provoquées par des
micro-organismes sur les végétaux
cultivés
s'ils sont des plantules de colza sur
lesquels nous avons inoculé l'agent
pathogène responsable des maladies
importantes par exemple ici vous voyez
une souche capable d'attaquer de faire
un symptôme est à côté incapable
d'attaquer de faire un simple
donc là on a un cas de souche virulente
sur cette variété est selon touche qui a
dit boehner c'est important pour nous de
cas ne permet de caractériser les
populations champions où les récoltes
dans ses recherches aboutissent à quoi
de manière plus générale
l'inra d'une manière générale est un
organisme qui fait des recherches à
vocation finalisé dans les domaines donc
de la de l'agronomie et
mais ça n'empêche qu'on fait aussi des
recherches assez fondamental parce que
par exemple chercheurs nous essayons de
comprendre comment notamment
interagissent tu les agents pathogènes
des plantes avec les plantes
pourquoi un agent pathogène est capable
d'attaquer une plante
comment une plante va être capable de
réagir à cet agent pathogène
on essaie de comprendre vraiment un
niveau moléculaire
comment ça se passe mais ça à des
applications parce que ça va nous
permettre de faire déconseillent
l'utilisation de certaines variétés de
par exemple de colza moi je serai sur le
colza de des variétés qui vont être
résistantes ou sensibles à une maladie
c'est important de connaître pour bien
gérer au fait ces résistances d'accord à
terme ça peut donner des vaccins alors
dans les plantes il n'y a pas de système
immunitaire comme chez un mammifère
mais il ya quand même des mécanismes de
résistance actif qu'on connaît pas
encore très très bien mais ne sont pas
des rappels des vaccins mais ça va être
une amélioration des variétés en
exploitant la diversité naturelle qui
existe dans les espèces on va essayer de
rechercher des espèces plus résistantes
que d'autres mais aussi adapté aux
populations de l'agent pathogène dans
cette
unité on travaille plus du côté de
l'agent pathogène que de la plante en
fait mais plutôt des microbiologistes
quelque part d'accord alors dans le
cadre de la fête de la science vous avez
vous même participé au speed dating
comment vulgaris ton la science auprès
d'un large public
c'est une question qui est pas évidente
souvent les grands publics pose des
questions qui sont très très pertinentes
qui aussi nous amène à voir nos
approches d'une manière un petit peu
différente
alors comment arriver à vulgariser
vraiment il faut essayer d'adapter son
langage à la personne qui est en phase
suivante il s'agit d'un enfant d'une
personne âgée ou d'un étudiant enfin
c'est il faut arriver à adapter son
langage au public
merci beaucoup de nous avoir aussi dans
vos locaux
nous allons maintenant aborder la
déperdition d'énergie au sein de nos
locaux professionnels et de nos
habitations grâce aux mesures
thermographique les saint quentinois
sont désormais informés quant à la
déperdition d'énergie au sein de leur
habitat regardez on n'a pas du tout
le monde toutes les missives racing team
où
moi on est
on va pouvoir grâce à cet outil l'avoir
plusieurs niveaux de couleurs qui vont
aller du bleu très clair au rouge très
foncé et en fait donc le bleu va plutôt
correspondre à des coups à des
déperditions faible et le rouge à des
déperditions importante
malgré tout il ya un certain niveau
d'interprétation qui va être difficile à
effectuer par rapport à certains niveaux
un certain nature de toiture tels que
les toitures en zinc
c'est une première dans l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines
les habitants peuvent désormais
connaître la déperdition d'énergie de
leur toiture initiatives prises dans le
cadre de sa politique de développement
durable
les mesures ont été réalisées en hiver
quand les habitations sont chauffés et
par temps clair pour réaliser ces
mesures nous disposons d'un scanner
infrarouge un capteur qui nous permet de
mesurer le rayonnement infrarouge des
toitures qui est intégrée dans un avion
un avion bimoteur qui nous permet de
voler la nuit à 500 mètres d'altitude au
dessus des zones urbaines
j'ai appris que
les travaux qu'on avait fait récemment
avait servi à isoler la maison et qu'on
avait un bon résultat en termes de
déperdition de chaleur donc ça ça me
conforte un petit peu dans ce qu'on a
réalisé auparavant
les saint quentinois peuvent donc
désormais s'informer sur l'isolation
thermique de leur habitat libres à eux
ensuite de se rapprocher d'un conseiller
afin de trouver des solutions pour
réduire leurs dépenses énergétiques
assez s'achève ce nouveau numéro d'
équilibre spécial science merci de
l'avoir suivi avant de nous quitter
voici quelques dates à noter dans vos
agendas la maison de l'environnement de
magny les hameaux propose une exposition
sur les énergies renouvelables la maison
de l'environnement toujours organise une
conférence sur le thème comment
envisager un autre futur
une autre manière de consommer et de
produire son énergie
et puis pour les plus jeunes dès 6 ans
la médiathèque de guyancourt organise un
atelier expérience et manipulations afin
que les enfants découvrent les
différentes énergies naturelles et
artificielles
nous on se retrouve le 16 novembre
prochain merci d'avoir suivi ce numéro
ciao